When your app gets some
super cool new information
that your user might like,
how can it share that info
without being disruptive?
I'm Joanna Smith, and
I'm here to tell you
how Snackbar just might
change your life forever,
or your app at least.
One of the finer points of
communicating information
in your application has to do
with on-screen notifications,
but when that information is
critical or requires the user
to make a decision, you
probably want to use an alert.
Historically, you had two
approaches here-- first,
a dialog could present
information to the user
that they would then act on.
But dialogs are interruptive
and force the users
to stop what they are doing
and deal with your dialog.
I mean, do you enjoy
being interrupted?
Do you love confirming
that you really
wanted to do the thing
that you were doing?
Do just like push dialogs?
I mean, this is kind
of annoying, isn't it?
So dialogs should really
be used sparingly,
which brings us around to the
second approach-- Toast, which
you can use to confirm that the
thing that the user was doing
really did happen.
But what if the action was
destructive like a deletion?
Your user might not
have meant to do that,
and now they are panicking
and looking for the undo
and wondering why you didn't
double check before deleting
that super cute pic.
OMG.
Are you trying to ruin my life?
And that is where the
Snackbar comes in.
Snackbars are
similar to a Toast,
but they're more
versatile in that they're
interactive like offering
that undo your user
is still searching for.
A Snackbar animates upward
from the bottom of the screen,
and you can swipe
it away, or not.
If you do nothing, it
will time out on its own
and automatically
disappear, and Snackbars
contain a short string
message, and they
can offer a single
action, such as an undo.
So now you have
three components that
will help you interrupt your
users in the perfect way.
Use the dialog when
the user's response
is critical to your app
flow, because you need to be
disruptive in these moments.
But use a Toast to give a
user a tidbit of information
that doesn't change anything.
And for everything in
between, the Snackbar
is your new best friend.
And so there you have it--
another great material design
principle brought
to life in your app.
So check out the
Design Library for all
of the support you need
to introduce Snackbars
to your own app, and
have fun in the world
of non-disruptive alerts.
But most importantly, just
continue to build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]